forty years after John Carpenter's
classic horror Halloween first hit the
big screen Jamie Lee Curtis is back as
Laurie Strode and a sequel that sees the
former baby sister attempt to turn the
tables on the murderous Michael Myers
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm revealing the secret truth
about the new Halloween movie and
Michael Myers including 10 freaky facts
you need to know about the film if
you're new here I do regular deep dives
into your favorite flicks
so tap the Bell and also leave me a
comment about the movie for a chance to
win one of these cool Halloween merch
packs and make sure you stay to the end
of the video to find out some secret
cameos in the film when it came to
creating memorable death scenes for the
inhabitants of Haddonfield the
filmmakers behind the new movie wanted
to make the kind of striking images that
are still burned into their brains like
terrifying postcards many years after
they first saw John Carpenter's original
Halloween but just how did the new
creative team go back producing
spine-chilling images of Michael Myers
victims after their deaths
well once director David Gordon Green
knew exactly what Deathly scene he
wanted to be seared into audiences Minds
oscar-winning special effects makeup
designer Christopher Nelson set about
creating it by making life casts of the
actors whose characters are killed with
specific expressions the designer then
Reece cop did the cast for dramatic
effect slightly over accentuating their
expressions and stylizing them to give a
terrifying inhumanity in fact Nelson's
creations turned out to be so freaky
that when actress Andy matichek who
plays Jamie Lee Curtis is on-screen
granddaughter first saw one of the
corpses he'd made in his workshop it was
so horrific Lee real that she refused to
go anywhere near it to bring the shape
aka Michael Myers back to life the
filmmakers turned to actor stuntman
James pude Courtney who impressed them
with his ability to channel the
character's enigmatic methodical nature
and Courtney found inspiration for his
performance in some rather freaky places
first of all there was Courtney's
encounter with a real-life hitman who he
met many years earlier through a mutual
acquaintance - professional assassin
live with the actor for a while as he
wanted his life story written and
Courtney said he absorbed a lot just by
hanging out with
man every day but that's not all after
watching a film about a contract killer
that Courtney appeared in the real-life
assassin gave the app to the lowdown on
how trained killers really work years
later Courtney took what he learned from
that experience especially the hit man's
emphasis on the importance of stealth
and efficiency and translated it into
his portrayal of Michael Myers an
efficient way he kills his victims in
fact according to Jamie Lee Curtis
something changed when Courtney pert
Myers mask on the combination of his
lack of human response and his physical
strength came out in a visceral and
emotional way for his version of Michael
Myers Courtney didn't just channel
contract killers though he also took
cues from cats yes to help the actor
create a Myers that was capable of
emotionless rampage director David
Gordon Green suggested he look at cats
in the wild such as leopards and
cheetahs that don't rationalize anything
other than what's in their path so to
get the kind of cat-like quality to
Myers movement which the director wanted
on-screen Courtney used the way his own
cat plays and hunts as a reference and
this isn't the first time the actor has
looked to a cat for ideas about a
character in the late 90s Courtney
appeared in an episode of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and used a cat to design
his movement for his demonic character
on the show for Courtney cats are the
most perfect hunting killing machines on
the planet and the beauty of it is we
don't judge a cat for what a cat does so
the actor carried that movement and the
non-judgmental approach to the way he
moved as the shape Nick Castle he played
the original Michael Myers in the very
first Halloween movie also passed on
some valuable nuggets of information to
the filmmakers about playing the shape
based on his own experience of the
character in the 70s Castle gave advice
about little subtle character traits for
example how Michael Myers turns or tilts
his head to observe a kill and also how
he sits up at a 90 degree angle without
using his hands all of which the
director found useful for the new film
however Nick Castle actually credits
director John Carpenter the person who
came up with the idea of the now classic
head tilt back in 1978
according to Castle during filming
carpenter told him to stand and look at
the character Myers had just killed then
tilts his head to the right and to the
left at the time Castle didn't realize
what carpenter was trying to achieve
with that little instruction but when he
saw the final film he was blown away by
the director's brilliant idea to make it
look like Myers was admiring his kill
most of the time you see the shape
on-screen he's being played by James
Jude Courtney however fans of John
Carpenter's classic will be happy to
hear that the original actor Nick Castle
does have a cameo in the new movie make
sure you look out for the first time
that Laurie sees the shape because
that's castle under the Michael Myers
mask director David Gordon Green
specifically asked the veteran actor to
perform Myers classic head tilt once
more a move which apparently gave
everyone onset goosebumps and actually
Castle also got to pass the Michael
Myers torch onto new actor James Jude
Courtney in that same scene Laura sees
the shape it's Nick and it's I in the
same scene so she's in the first shot
and they revealed that I'm in the second
part of that shot and then I carried the
torch from that point forward so it's
literally handing of the baton man yes
now while castles on screen time as
Myers is sure that's not his only
contribution to the new movie listen
carefully for any scenes where you can
hear Maya's breathing because the sound
you hear are actually Nick Cassel who
recorded the shapes breathing in
post-production an absolutely crucial
part of the Halloween movies is Maya's
creepy mask which actually started out
life as a store-bought William Shatner
Captain Kirk mask before its eye holes
were made bigger its hair was altered
and it was spray-painted white all of
which gave it the iconic look we know
today for the new movie rather than put
their own spin on the mask the
filmmakers decided to try to recreate
the original strange soulless mannequin
like face and most importantly the
feeling it inspired in audiences but it
wasn't nearly as simple as it sounds
because for decades of passed since
Michael Myers first wore the mask and
the latex would have changed shape after
so long in evidence storage
fortunately the movie had special
effects makeup designer Christopher
Nelson on board to get the right look
Nelson has a real grasp of the history
of both the franchise and the mask as
he's been a fan of the series since he
saw the first movie when he was 10 years
old the designer researched how 40 year
old latex decomposes and
did how it looks when it gets brittle
wrinkles warps and sags all of which was
essential for how he created the new
mask while still keeping the expression
and form of the original one for Nelson
another vital element of the mask from
the original film was that it looked
different in each shot so he channeled
that feeling into the new film making
the new deteriorated mask look different
to every angle to give a sense that the
mask was constantly shape-shifting
according to Jamie Lee Curtis her
unofficial godson Jake Gyllenhaal was so
keen for her to work with director David
Gordon Green that he tracked her down
while she was on vacation in the
mountains Gyllenhaal was really
enthusiastic about the amazing creative
experience he'd had working with green
on the Boston Marathon bombing film
stronger and that convinced Curtis to
speak with the director about his ideas
for a new Halloween movie however when
she signed on to return to the screen
once more as Laurie Strode Curtis
assumed the movie would focus more on
Laurie's daughter and granddaughter and
it was only once Curtis started working
through her character's psychological
trauma in rehearsals that she realized
the real depth of the work she'd taken
on not only was the shoot emotionally
moving with plenty of Tears but it was
also physically draining in terms of
stunt work and Curtis ended up with a
cracked rib after shooting the film's
final sequences in fact she says it took
her a good months to recover afterwards
given the story's late-october setting
and several memorable moments in the
original movie including its opening
credits it's hardly surprising to see
jack-o'-lanterns on display in the new
film Bert's getting hold of the hundreds
of fresh pumpkins that were needed in
time for the movies mid-january shoot in
Charleston South Carolina proved to be
rather tricky set decorator Missy Ricker
ended up having to bring in truckloads
of them from North Carolina and she also
had to ensure she had many dozens of
pumpkins of the same size and shape so
they could be used for any scenes that
needed to be filmed many times over on
top of that the set decorating team also
had to work out how to preserve the
pumpkins so they were always
camera-ready throughout the shoot the
key to that particular problem turned
out to be dipping them in vats of a
bleach solution Nick Castle isn't the
only star of the original film he makes
a brief return in the new movie actor
Donald Pleasence his character dr.
Samuel Lewis has been a major part of
the Halloween franchise since it began
and while Pleasant
Dawei in the 1990s dr. Loomis still gets
a vocal cameo in the new film although
it's not the voice of Pleasants himself
the filmmakers are pretty pleased with
the result of the sound and like voice
actor they found for the role of course
this isn't the first time that dr.
Loomis has been recreated by a voice
actor as that also happened in the 1998
film Halloween h2o and I'm going to talk
more about Loomis in my halloween
deleted scenes video which you can tap
here to watch by the way in this new
film also listen out for PJ Souls who
played Laurie's friend Linda in the 1978
movie and who makes a brief appearance
here as a teacher whose voice you'll
hear during one of Allison's classes now
if you've seen Halloween what did you
think and where do you rank it against
the other Halloween movies let me know
what you think in the comments below and
remember to subscribe for a chance to
win one of these cool Halloween merch
packs the winner of my velum Funko pop
is on screen now so if you're the winner
message me via email to claim the prize
tapleft to watch my new Halloween ending
and twist explain video or tap write for
my full horror playlist if you enjoyed
this I really appreciate a thumbs up and
a share thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers